so you see they let that dude off the
Empire guy yeah I did see that I let him
slide I love it makes it so exciting for
me I've been I've been while last couple
days tell my girlfriend go I go the
craziest thing would be if they say he's
not guilty because then you have to go
what happened what happened what
happened did he bribe somebody or did
some new evidence come forth that they
had a bad investigation did the two guys
that were his witnesses did they get
caught lying about something else
you know the witnesses against him they
might have caught them lying about
something else and they don't know what
to do and they have to abandon the case
because then they're they obviously know
that he's a lot these guys lied about
something who the fuck knows man I know
I can make a guest miss they won't be
educated but just knowing Chicago in
general I mean my guess is maybe the way
they were going after an investigation
wasn't really aboveboard and if they if
they he's just like I'm not guilty and
they have to actually go in and present
this evidence they don't have you know
that they don't have what they really
need to have you know like I don't I
don't think anyone's going around like
okay yeah well then those two Nigerian
maca guys did a tackle on Magra guys
it's so great well then they also they
sealed the case so fun yeah it's crazy
yeah if you wanted like a good twist you
know in the movie like this is a crazy
scene in the movie were crazy music is
playing and you see Jessie Smollett come
out in slow motion and put his
sunglasses on and get into the limo not
guilty music and he comes out in slow
motion and gets in the limo and then
dudes are wearing ski masks if people
are pulled on it's like like one ongoing
story and one of those Tarantino movies
we got for stories like Pulp Fiction
battling it out he's one of them or he
gets not guilty and it becomes a big
twist because you feel like you find out
there's some behind-the-scenes
shenanigans and shit that led to this
yeah because what happens we were like
oh he's never going to work again and
but now not guilty so does he get his
own show it's good question what well
the other thing is for a little longest
time Chicago
has been thought to be a place that is
like a you know but things can happen
there you can make shit happen right is
that a fair way to say it I love Chicago
I don't want to be disparaging but
there's been some some cases of
corruption oh yeah no I mean that's
where I was raised
it'll very cool place most of our mayors
and stuff go to jail so I don't think
I'm being unfair yeah there's uh there
was a scene in a movie what was the
scene in the movie where someone's
Chicago is the most corrupt big city
Illinois third most state in the country
mafia ties yeah that's great published
February 15th the shit this is recent
oh my goodness